so we were both servers I found out you
were a server as well I think all of it
real server I was never a server oh my
god you're the only actor I've ever met
that's never certainly paid another job
I know isn't that bad that's so great
kind of though I feel like I've had
every job yes yeah I loved serving
actually well I was a cocktail waitress
and where did you serve a comedy club ok
don't ok good vibes good energy no it
was happy was good
did you like serving or no absolutely
not I worked with I love I think it's
cool it was the restaurant I was at
because I was more than a server I had
to like sometimes I don't have to cook
like if it was dessert god forbid
somebody order dessert I had to go in
the back and make it myself like for
real like I had to I was my own busser I
was like The busboy I had to bust my own
tables I had to like scrape the you know
how did you work I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this